[Music]
thanks to everyone who came out thank to
everyone from who heard about it on
coasts for coming such an exciting day
who's ready to see Kevin and Jay get
down in the wet cement and then be
immortalized forever what a special
place to do it too so it's my honor to
introduce to you Ben Affleck
all right thank you thank you thank you
very much thank you
all right it's the last day I'm gonna
put up with that bomb and phantoms joke
I'm very excited I'm very honored to be
rhinos supposed to be about like Kevin
and Jay but keeping with Hollywood
tradition I'd like to make it about me
so I came out to LA I was a struggling
actor and I was sort of awkward and big
and goofy looking and I guess I must
have been kind of off-putting because I
couldn't even get an audition for like
the leading roles of anything but every
time some project showed up the casting
director would be like they're not
interested in you for any of the main
parts but there is a kind of a douchey
unpleasant villain that we think you
would be right for and so I played that
part in the school ties I was the
douchey anti-semite Daisy confused I was
the annoying villain who chased people
around with the paddle and then won
director had the singular vision to cast
me as the annoying douchey guy with a
suit and Mallrats
which I for be forever grateful one of
them is the director of the movie was
the guy who could not stop talking about
himself the other one was the directors
friend who had only ever acted one time
before and a black-and-white movie
called clerks and the two of them had a
kind of a special relationship that I
couldn't quite figure out they were
either brothers or best friends or a
surrogate father and a wayward son or
possibly husband and wife you know they
were sweet but they they cursed like
sailors to be honest in fact this is a
true story I subsequently did a USO tour
and was taken on an aircraft carrier and
the XO said you know some of these guys
cursed like Jay and Silent Bob
the offspring dynamic they had was
really kind of adorable because you know
in the in the movies the big one
followed the little one around but a
real-life little one followed the bigger
one around all the time so whether they
were working or not they were kind of
always together like Snoopy and
Woodstock by way of Bill and Ted sort of
work Bert and Ernie by way of Cheech and
Chong they were they were loyal to each
other for whatever reason and suddenly
they were loyal to this guy from Boston
who they barely knew and they may be
part of their view askew family and the
little one would say kind of nonsensical
things like snoogantay poochie's and
call people yous guys and the bigger one
would say nonsensical things like mall
rats gonna make a hundred million
dollars selling me off by 98 million
even more nonsensical he said I'm gonna
make you the lead of my next movie and
they may say a lot of nonsensical things
but they don't [ __ ] and I did get a
big role in the directors next movie and
the next one and the next one and the
next one and for a while I feel like we
were like Scorsese and De Niro you know
if none of Scorsese and De Niro's movies
got critical acclaim or made any money
or got any awards and we're all set in
New Jersey so his his little friend was
kind of our joke Joe Pesci character the
motormouth clown who amused everybody
but who you kind of knew was somehow
secretly sort of a genius and we built
our careers together about laughing and
learning about the movie business we
dreamed our dreams together and so a lot
of them came true and it was it was
really the most fun I ever had making
movies absolutely the least profitable
but the most fun for sure in fact you
know I really owe Kevin mm-hmm for
starting my own career off as a
filmmaker when I was doing Mallrats
I kept telling him how I was you know me
my friend we wanted to write the script
and you know I finally got the courage
up and asked him to read it and I flew
out of town I came back and he pulled me
aside he said I want you to know I start
reading your script on the toilet I said
thank you because I didn't get off until
I finished it
which turns out as Kevin's highest form
of praise but he was very encouraging
the idea that like some guy with no
connections and no money and no in my
case education to speak of could
actually like get a movie made and have
something to say and make a contribution
and he's an executive producer on that
movie and my my really principal main
regret about the Oscars and that home
movie is that on Oscar night I neglected
to thank heaven because I was kind of
overwhelmed and there really would be no
Good Will Hunting script certainly
wouldn't have gotten made without him so
I want to take this opportunity to
remedy that pretend that I'm on the
stage the Oscars and say thank you Kevin
Smith very very much
[Music]
when I told people you know they reached
out to me to do their movie their new
movie Jay and Silent Bob reboot and you
know they were always there for me and
so I really wanted to be there for them
in 22 years after chasing Amy I
pretended to be Holden McNeil again and
since Holden McNeil is really just the
writer director with a different name he
essentially asked me to play him this is
either the cheapest or the most
expensive form of therapy on the planet
but we got together and we shot our
scene and it was like finding your
favorite old t-shirt in a moving box and
it's still been you know after 25 years
these guys still fit they were like this
comfortable wonderful familiar t-shirt
of American movies and I think that's
kind of fitting you know because these
guys are sort of like the American dream
come true the American dream was to talk
about comic books and dissect love and
analyze Star Wars using every curse word
and the planet when I told people I was
gonna speak for them today mmm as they
got their handprints
cement at the Chinese Theatre the
average response was two things first
was really and the second one was good
for these guys and the first response
really I think is because when we think
of the Chinese Theatre footprints we
think of larger-than-life Hollywood
legends you know people like Jack
Nicholson or you know r2d2 and the guys
from Mallrats I feel like are sort of
joining that second group you know what
I mean and good for those guys comes
after that you know you do the math and
you realize that
these guys are Hollywood legends now we
don't think of them as such because
we've seen them hanging around the same
convenience store you don't think of
legends as the guys who saw you weed
outside 7-eleven and yet that's that's
who they are you know the legends aren't
people you actually know they're they're
legends and legends break the mold and
that's what these two have been doing
for a quarter a century breaking the
mold so over and over so it's dead the
reason they broke the legend mold too
they couldn't even do that the right way
because you know they're from New Jersey
keep the car running they've been
hanging around the Kwik Stop for 25
years but today Jay and Silent Bob's
start hanging around the tail TCL
Chinese Theatre courtyard forever
ensconced in cement with all the other
Hollywood legends right where they
belong
I'm really really grateful to these two
guys and I have to say I just love them
so much thank you and thank you thank
you very much so we have some more
special special words from Harley Quinn
welcome Harley hello today is a really
big day for me because not one but two
of my dad's are being presented with the
immense honor of getting their
handprints solidified in cement to
celebrate their long-lasting impact on
all of us I recently had the pleasure of
playing Jays daughter in Jay and Silent
Bob reboot and I have had the pleasure
of being the other one's daughter my
whole life I'm not going to lie to you
if you had told me that these two would
be getting this honor a couple of years
ago I wouldn't have believed you at the
time I just knew these two weirdos as my
dad and my uncle I knew that they could
both make me laugh more than pretty much
anyone and I knew that they were a
little more edgy than most people could
say about their family but
other than that I didn't exactly
understand why they were different at
the time when I was younger I was never
allowed to watch my dad's films my mom
told me that they were too inappropriate
and that I would not want to look my dad
in the face if I knew the type of
material he was writing so for the
longest time I didn't watch his films
then I got older and entered adulthood
and my dad started to become insulted
that I hadn't watched his films yet so I
slowly but surely started my journey
into the viewest universe I first
started with mole-rats than Jay and
Silent Bob strike back
I remember watching Jay and Silent Bob
and secretly thinking to myself wait
they're beating up people who have said
mean [ __ ] about them on the Internet
this is kind of genius but it wasn't
until August 2nd 2018 that I fully
understood what the fuss was about
I went to Bolger Thawne in New Jersey
with my dad for his birthday and that's
when I saw clerks for the first time my
entire life people have come up to my
dad and told him how clerks has changed
their lives and how much the characters
of Jay and Silent Bob have meant to them
and it always made me happy that my dad
and Jay had made such an impact on them
but I never really understood why
until I saw clerks for the first time I
watched it in a room full of my dad and
Jays biggest fans and I was able to see
how much it meant to each and every one
of them firsthand
I saw how inspirational this film was
and I saw how it influenced so many of
the films that I've loved my whole life
after watching clerks I finally
understood what the fuss was about I now
knew them not only as my uncle and dad
but as Jay and Silent Bob now getting
their handprints in front of the iconic
Chinese Theatre seems more than deserved
and quite honestly overdue Jay having
you be such a prevalent part of my life
has been one of the greatest gifts I
could have ever wished for I have never
known anyone who could make me laugh as
much as you you say things sometimes
that will literally make me laugh for
days to come and you are the craziest
person I know in the best possible way
you've also been there
for me my entire life and you've always
been someone who I could come to no
matter what being able to see you become
a father over the past four years has
been absolutely breathtaking
you are no offense you are and no
offense to my dad but you are the best
dad I have ever seen and Logan is so
lucky to have you it meant the world to
me to play your daughter and reboot
after watching you enter fatherhood in
real life
I feel so lucky to have you not only as
my uncle but now as an honorary dad as
well now dad my real dad you are
probably the most impeccable human I
have ever known I rarely talk about your
heart attack because it makes me too
upset to speak about but I feel it's
important to mention here the night of
your heart attack I slept at the
hospital on your couch I was scared
shitless waking up every hour so to
check on you that was the scariest day
of my entire life and as much as I'd
like to forget about it I do think it's
important to remember so that we can
compare to where you're at today you
have proven to everyone really just how
impressive of a human you are you came
back from your heart attack and
completely changed your life you went
vegan which was not really a choice as
much as it was forced upon you by me but
still you completely changed your life
and you are the healthiest you've ever
been not only did you change your
personal life but you came back and made
a movie which is really the end game of
your films you somehow managed to gather
everyone from your past to make a movie
you've been on a quest to make for years
you always joke and say that it's your
heart attack that made the movie
possible because everyone felt guilty
enough to come be a part of it but I
don't agree with that I think it's your
strength tenacity and perseverance that
made this possible my whole life you've
made a living by essentially making fun
of yourself but you are truly a magical
human being and I hope you know that you
have proven that you can literally do
anything that you set your mind to and
you inspire me endlessly you are my dad
my director but mostly my best friend
I'm so insanely
both of you and beyond thrilled that you
are receiving this honor today dad J I
love you more than I can possibly say
thank you for being the best dads I
could ever wish for so without further
ado and that was so beautiful from both
you Ben and Harley please welcome Kevin
Smith and Jamie oh my gosh I'm like
thrown aback back there I can hear about
SIA
me and Kevin balls back there crying
sorry the sweet things Ben and Harley
both said is is really amazing being
here is super surreal for me because I
mean who would like I wouldn't ever
thought that I'd be able to put my
handprints in here like Ben said earlier
like I walk by and you see big huge
names here and so for me to find out
when they told me that I was getting my
handprints in the cement out here was I
don't know it's still like floating over
but I don't know I'm not the wordsmith
here Kevin is but I do want to say man I
you'll see it's funny because he talks
more than me in real life and in the
movies you know I talk but I do want to
say thank you to Ben and Harley Harley
had me crying back there which wasn't a
good start so I'm like oh I gotta get
out there would say anything sweet but I
do want to thank you know I owe this all
to Kevin it's like Kevin saw me 13
year-old kid hanging around the
community center and said wow this kid
has a weird sense of humor and says
funny things and when he wrote his
script clerks he he thought to write me
in there and then he wrote me in the
next movie even though the studio fought
him on it and made me audition he still
fought for me
and then put me in the next movie in the
next movie and it wasn't something I
planned on doing with movies because I
just thought like oh one day I'm gonna
own my own roofing business and I'm
gonna be somebody and I don't have like
my family history I've talked about a
lot of my podcasts and stuff and I
mention X like my mom was in and out of
jail and I lived my grandma my aunt all
this but the reason I mentioned is
because Kevin not only like put me in a
movie and became someone I looked up to
became my friend but then he let me into
his family which you know I got to see
Harley be born and his wife Jen they
took me in and then I got to meet Gale
and Byron who were another extension of
my family and it really helped me stay
on course even when I had some troubles
with the drugs and stuff like he was
always there for me and I really owe
everything to Kevin you know the movies
and just being around because I always
he was always there to help me out
support me and then my wife I met my
wife Jordan Monsanto and she's been a
big strong part of me trying to you know
stay on the straight and narrow because
then we had a kid she's her name's Logan
I wanted to bring her today but my wife
wouldn't let me
I wanted to sneak her handprint in the
and the handprint thing but anyway I
appreciate everyone for being here
madness is such a big deal it's so
surreal to me if you told me I'd ever
get this I would tell you our liar and
it's amazing and thank you Kevin Harley
Ben Jen and Galen Byron and Jordan and
everyone else this is awesome now I'm
gonna let this guy talk get comfy
[ __ ]
first off I want to thank everybody for
showing up today I really want to thank
Ben and Harley for amazingly kind words
to anybody else noticed that we were
lucky enough to get both a Batman and
Harley Quinn - intro us makes a lot of
sense in my world ladies and gentlemen
to understand what this moment means to
me and my family got to take you back to
the 70s my father Don Smith was a postal
employee and he married this woman a
Jersey girl named Grace who is here
somewhere there's my mom my mom's here
today they had three kids Virginia
Donald and Kevin I was the last kid I
was born on my brother's birthday August
2nd he was born 66 August 2nd I was born
August 2nd 1970 interestingly enough my
sister was born on August 10th like a
year before my brother so we were all
born in August which means my parents
really like to [ __ ] in November election
[ __ ] so so Don Smith like didn't
really want for much I asked him once
when I was a kid like hey what were your
dreams when you were young dad like what
you want to do and he was like I wanted
to get married and have kids and so his
dreams happened early on his career
wasn't about what made him feel good in
life or fulfilled he's had to get a job
to pay for what made him feel good in
life what made him feel fulfilled his
wife and his kids and we were I'd like
to say lower lower lower lower lower
lower middle class and stuff but my mom
was a financial whiz who could make a
buck stretch and because of that even
though we're poor we would go on
vacations that was important to my dad
because he worked at the post office and
if he didn't go on vacations he might
have went postal and [ __ ] so he never
did we were very proud of him for that
he would go on these vacations and he
would take his places that
meant something to him and he took us
here in 1979 my family got on a train
from New Jersey me my mom my dad my
brother and sister and came to Hollywood
because I loved the movies I loved TV I
loved the movies I loved Hollywood when
I was growing up and that was what we
shared me and my father you know it was
like he told my mom the fat one likes
movies I'm gonna do movies with him and
stuff so he would take me to the movies
all the time and lean into my
fascination with the movie business even
though we were the furthest thing in the
world from it in New Jersey so we came
here to the courtyard in 1979 and walked
around for an hour looking at all the
footprints and handprints and naturally
there were some that were older than I
would remember and my father would
explain who they were you know my
brother and I knelt in front of r2d2
c-3po and Darth Vader's footprints and
my dad took a picture of us although my
sister says she took the picture so I
don't know memories foggy but I do
remember this moment it was that like
the chattiest guy in the world and stuff
but every once in a while he would say
something that like deeply impacted and
since he was my dad and since all
parents are God to a child everything he
said at that age impacted particularly
when we were here in Hollywood he'd
taken us to Hollywood
and here we were standing amongst all
the stars and the legends he took the
picture mold man as were gone through
all the footprints and [ __ ] oh man says
six stupid [ __ ] words six stupid
things that you say to a [ __ ] kid
when you're at a baseball field if
they're into baseball or any sports or
or if there's some place where they have
a vague interest in it and stuff
my old man was looking at the footprints
and he saw me looking at the footprints
put my hands and the handprints and
stuff and he said this stupid [ __ ] that
you just say to a kid passed the time
nice thing to say he goes maybe you'll
be here one day he didn't mean it he
wasn't planning it he wasn't planting a
seed we had no path to this world
whatsoever it's just some stupid [ __ ]
they
you say to your kid to pass the time but
ladies and gentlemen you have to be
careful of the stupid [ __ ] you say to
your kids
sometimes it takes deep root because of
that I've been telling my kids since she
was a child you know one day you'll be a
billionaire who financed all my movies
and [ __ ] just just in case it [ __ ]
worked like it did on me the last time
me and my mom and my brother and my
sister we're in this courtyard was with
my dad in 1979 it's 40 years from that
moment when my father said it this was
left of my father ladies and gentlemen
this is some of his ashes this is the
first time in 40 years my whole family
is back together again this courtyard
and I couldn't imagine a better [ __ ]
reason for it thank you Dad
[Applause]
in the way of thanks let me just keep
going so many people of course I thank
my dad I thank my mom who was always
incredibly supportive and the second
biggest Kevin Smith fan on the planet me
being the first I thank my sister who
taught me what writing was you know at
an early age I found a composition
notebook that she had under her bed and
inside there was a drawing of her
friends around a door and a cover page
is what secret and cell it was is secret
secrets beyond the trapdoor and I said
what is this and she said I'm writing a
book and I was like you can't just write
a book you have to ask the government
and stuff and she's like why do you say
that is because we had to get like a
library card to take books out of the
library I was very young and so she said
you don't need permission from the
government to write anybody can write
anything you can write anything anytime
you want
anyways free to write I spend my life
writing my brother was my absolute first
audience you don't know if you could do
something unless you try it and then
somebody says good job I wrote a story
about going to visit
our relatives remember and like I
scariest thing in the world is like
taking a piece of yourself putting it
down handing it to somebody else and
saying what do you think and I was a kid
so I needed approval and I handed it to
him because my brother's the best
laugher in the world man when he laughs
at [ __ ] you really feel like you're
funny and he laughed at it and not at it
but with it and he said it was good and
I watched him read the words and like
his emotions change and I felt like a
wizard the magician magic words change
the emotions and the man's body and
stuff like that that impacted in a big
bad way gave me something to chase like
a dragon from my whole life I want to
thank everyone I ever worked with like
Ben and Harley of course recently all
the actors I've ever worked with Brian O
Hara is here Maryland is here the people
that absolutely dreamed with Nate and
made it all possible brought words to
life and what not
I thank Byron and Gail Jen's parents who
have always been there for me of course
I thank my wife who brought me out here
I didn't want to leave New Jersey and
she said there's a better way to live
and and we came out here we've been out
here for almost 20 years and that means
everything because this is the only
other place than New Jersey that I ever
wanted to be that I ever wanted to live
was in Hollywood she gave me a beautiful
daughter who I now make movies with
Harley makes the job fun again
I was never losing interest but suddenly
my kid was interested in movies I'm like
I know a thing or two about movies like
don't listen to the critics I do and
suddenly I was able to start working
with her as a professional
so I thank her for giving me like a
second chance not just by making me
vegan and whatnot used to be happy now
I'm [ __ ] vegan
but she saved my life you know in doing
so I want to thank Ellie and Lisa for
letting us do this wonderful people who
we met in San Diego would put our hands
in the cement and I told them what it
meant to me and he was like we could do
that here and I was what like suddenly I
was going to be amongst people I've
looked up to my whole life other
Hollywood legends thank you so much for
that thank you to all the people who are
working on Jay and Silent Bob reboot
right now Saban Films Universal Rob my
publicist Rogers and Carolyn everybody
who's trying to help out right now movie
comes out this week we're very excited
big thanks go out to jordan monsanto
jason's
good lady white for the last 10 years
Jason and I have been saying things to
Jordan like we want to do this we want
to do that we would like to do this and
Jordan always finds a way to facilitate
it man we're all just idea people unless
you find somebody who can make manifest
your dreams I'm just a dreamer I need
somebody to make the dreams a reality
Jordan made Jay and Silent Bob reboot a
reality for us man so without her this
doesn't happen Thank You Jordan and
lastly I want to turn this out to the
audience
number one thank you for paying
attention for the last 25 years that has
meant the world obviously I need a lot
of validation and and you've been giving
me that in like crazy I just want to
tell you that this is doable you you
could do this I'm not very special I
just took a chance and said some [ __ ]
about myself i self-express t' and if
you look at this world and you're
remotely like i love the movie business
and stuff like that come join us
Hollywood is a magical place it sounds
ridiculous to say but it really is in
many ways a great equalizer bringing all
sorts of diversity together in the
pursuit of of the dream of telling the
story of capturing and imagination of
making people for
for one day for one moment like their
troubles or that you know one day
they're gonna die and stuff is it's a
great business in Hollywood is a great
town a magical town and when I was a kid
I believed that and I've lived here for
almost 20 years and I still absolutely
believe that believe in Hollywood is the
land of hope and dreams man and I can't
get out of here without quoting a poet
who means the world to me he's also from
New Jersey his name is Bruce Springsteen
and he wrote a song called land of hope
and dreams men this is I think it really
applies to our town in our business the
refrain chorus goes this train which
refers to this town this train carries
saints and sinners this train carries
losers and winners this train carries
[ __ ] and gamblers this train carries
lost souls this train carries
brokenhearted thieves and sweet Souls
departed this train carries fools and
carries kings this train all aboard this
train dreams will not be thwarted this
train of faith will be rewarded meet me
in a land of hope and dreams ladies and
gentlemen we're in the land of hope and
dreams and thank you for letting me hang
out with you this long I love you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so these are the test runs before you go
out and put your name and hands and
cement here in the TCL Chinese Theatre
you do a test run and I was here when
Stan did his because I was M seeing
Stan's ceremony so I remember coming in
here and watching Stan like see if you
could write and smack because it's not
that easy and then you test put your
hands in so that you're not doing it out
there for the first time so I remember
standing by I'm watching him do it and
then we came in today and we did the
same thing where they walk you through
it and go ahead right and put your hands
is what it feels like so you get
familiar with it
so that's mine that's Jay has come close
I'll show you look at so confident big
letters and then at the end all smooshed
at just so terrible thank God I didn't
even get the Bob that's a Bob can't even
tell Jay expert first run try write
their name fits all the way across put
his name in quotes and stuff
thank got practice makes perfect it's a
good thing that we do practice and stuff
that was a excellent practice run and
then we went out there and it was crazy
crazy wonderful man
we put our hands in the cement our feet
in the cement we left a little piece of
our hearts and souls in Hollywood today
and it was I loved it brought my dad
with me because my dad brought us here
1979 and so I bought my dad's ashes
because it's the first time since 79 and
me and my mom and my dad and my brother
and sister were all in the courtyard at
the same time so it was kind of special
and then I before I left I put my dad's
urn in the cement so you know now he's
he's there as well he gets a little
piece of it
[Music]